hannity moments ago president wrapping
up yet another huge rally this time in
pennsylvania
thousands lining up this case in the
rain earlier today for hours
in what is a true testament to the
president's resilience
and the rapid advancement of america
american therapeutics
donald trump is now crisscrossing the
country only days after his very swift
recovery from covet 19 the media doesn't
say
oh i want you to have the exact same
therapeutics i have and i will give it
to every american that needs it for free
soon as they can get the fda approval oh
how come the media didn't cover that
meanwhile his opponent joe biden can
barely cross the delaware state line
without becoming
let's see confused and sleepy and
irritated
former white house physician dr ronnie
jackson is
sounding the alarm as most americans can
see
about biden's well mental fitness for
office
we'll get his take straight ahead
tonight also speaker pelosi had a public
meltdown on fake news cnn earlier today
and she doesn't want to answer any
questions about why she's blocking a
second covert 19 stimulus package
we will play you the low lights of her
meltdown but first we begin tonight
judge amy coney barrett is well on her
way now to becoming
the newest justice of the united states
supreme court she
ran circles around the democratic
senators at today's hearing
she made them frankly look stupid
unprepared desperate
she exposed the absolute hatred that now
defines this new radical insane and
extreme democratic socialist party
she did it with a calm unflappable
demeanor
and a solid command of facts without a
single note in front of her take a look
does the constitution give the president
of the united states the authority
to unilaterally delay a general election
under any circumstances
does federal law if i'd give off the
cuff
answers then i would be basically a
legal pundit
and i don't think we want judges to be
legal pundits i think we want judges to
approach cases
thoughtfully and with an open mind is
row a super precedent
how would you define super precedent i
i actually i might have thought someday
i'd be sitting in that chair i'm not i'm
up here so i'm asking okay
well people use super precedent
differently okay are you willing to say
that roe was correctly decided
because that's really the essence of the
question here
well senator as i've said you know to
others of your colleagues in response to
questioning
that it's inconsistent with the duties
of a sitting judge
and therefore has been the practice of
every nominee that sat in the seat
before me to take
positions on cases that the court has
decided
in the past since you became a legal
adult have you ever
made unwanted requests for sexual favors
or committed any verbal
or physical harassment or assault over
sexual nature
no senator hirono have you ever faced
discipline
or entered into a settlement related to
this kind of conduct
now senator but i want to just ask you
very simply i
imagine you'll give me a very short
resolute answer
um but you condemn white supremacy
correct
yes thank you i'm glad to see
that you said that i wish our president
uh
would say that so resolutely
unequivocally as well
he's only said it a million times we've
played it a million times
judge amy coney barrett or judge acb as
she's now being called
her track record is impeccable she is
more qualified to serve on the highest
court in the land and
well a lot of sitting justices now so
now senator spartacus and his democratic
colleagues
they're engaging in little more than
performance theater
a baby temper tantrum here and there
something they're
frankly very familiar with and that's
why
we saw all of the props today in fact
far left senator sheldon whitehouse was
so busy
with his large cardboard prince that he
forgot to ask
judge amy coney barrett a single
question for 30 straight minutes
and by contrast well judge acv
had no props no preparedness whatsoever
nothing take a look you know most of us
have
multiple notebooks and notes and books
and things like that in front of us can
you hold up what you've been referring
to and answering
our questions
is there anything on it uh that
letterhead that says united states
senate
that's imp that's impressive democrats
completely outmatched completely
outclassed but that won't stop them from
doing anything and everything imaginable
to block judge barrett's confirmation
now we know the game plan we all
remember what they did to justice
kavanaugh and his family
they tried to ruin this man's life and
forever destroy
his reputation in what was nothing but a
politically
calculated and coordinated hit job they
ripped away his presumption of innocence
all due process
they made reckless baseless false
accusations one after another
they put this country through hell all
in their attempt then to upend his
confirmation
watch this judge kavanagh you should not
be
serving in this building as a
supreme court justice judge kavanaugh
is your worst nightmare not only do
women
like dr ford who bravely comes forward
need to be heard
but they need to be believed they need
to be believed i just want to say to the
men of this country
just shut up and step up let's look at
uh
beach week ralph club biggest
contributor what does the word ralph
mean in that uh that probably refers to
uh throwing up
drinking is one thing but the concern is
about truthfulness
and in your written testimony you said
sometimes you had too many drinks
was there ever a time when you drank so
much that you couldn't remember what
happened
or part of what happened the night
before so will they ever apologize for
their treatment of justice kavanaugh
apologize to his family will they ever
apologize for the
high-tech lynching you remember what
they did to justice clarence thomas
well they ever to the family of
robert bork and the false accusations
made against him of course not for
democrats
nothing is ever off the table lies smear
slander
it's all a means to an end by the way
buckle up and prepare for the worst
but so far judge amy coney barrett acb
is doing a remarkable job and making
them look pretty
well small